hi and welcome to my video series of
cell signaling in this video we'll be
talking about g-protein coupled receptor
signaling under phototransduction now
vision is one of the best special senses
because that allow us to see the world
and how beautiful it is right now let us
try to understand but it's the molecular
mechanism and neurobiological aspect
underlying their vision now this is our
eye at the back of the eye there is a
screen
known as retina inside retina there are
several layers of cells and we get to
know about the cells in shortly now
among these cells there is one
particular type of cell which is known
as rod cells this rod cells give us
sensitivity towards low-light vision
there is another version known as cone
cell which allow us to see a color
division in the rod cell in the
peripheral region of the rod cell there
are pigments known as rhodopsin which
are located in these membrane
imaginations known as discs now in Rod
of rhodopsin there are specific pockets
and in these pockets of the rhodopsin
you can find a molecule known as retinol
to be specific is 11 sis retinol
elevenses retinol is embedded in the
deep hydrophobic pocket of this
g-protein coupled receptor rhodopsin
when light hits this particular
rhodopsin molecule there is a
conformational change which leads to
conversion of 11
sis retinol to a transform at a trans
retinal now this conformational change
has consequences but before that let me
tell you that the retinal is actually
derived from beta-carotene beta-carotene
is cleaved in specific places
it's poly preneur chain to give rise to
all transfer a Chanel which is the
pigment inside the rhodopsin which is
the photo transducing system inside the
rhodopsin now let us look at the
signaling transduction mechanism with
more details so rhodopsin as it's a
g-protein coupled receptor it's seven
transmembrane domain coupled receptor
and it has like seven transmembrane
domains now rhodopsin is generally
coupled with a g-protein a trimeric
g-protein which is known as transducing
trans tuning deucing has three G protein
subunits alpha beta and gamma just like
a GS signalling regime now when light
hits what happens is few things first of
all after hitting the light the external
hallucis of rhodopsin gets tilted as a
result there is a opening of a site in
which the transducing can get interact
interaction and as a result what happens
is in the transducing there is a
hydrolysis of GDP and there is an
exchange of gtp now once in a gtp bound
State transducing is active the active
transducing leave the trimeric state and
activate another phosphodiester s
molecule a particular enzyme which is
destined to degrade phosphodiester bond
and it actually converts cyclic
guanosine monophosphate into only GMP s
now what is the consequence of that and
what what type of relation does it have
with division we'll get to know soon now
normally when there is a dark state or
there is an absence of light there are
cyclic nucleotide gated channels which
are basically cyclic GMP Garrett
channels these channels allow sodium
influx inside the cell and that's why
the cells were always depolarized
now when there is no light the sales are
depolarized I repeat when there is no
light or in a dark situation the sales
are depolarized State this might be
pretty much awkward for you but this is
the case we always think ok the light
would activate the neuron and that would
lead the signal transduction but here
these photoreceptor neurons they have a
different regime they're always active
they are constitutively active they are
always firing but when the light hits
them they stop firing now in a moment it
would be very clear so stay tuned now
what happens is when cyclic GMP is
cyclic GMP is actually degraded to only
GMP by the action of phosphodiester is
the level of cyclic GMP falls down as a
result the slightly GMB gated channels
no more pumping sodium inside the cells
right now what happens is the cells
become hyper polarized because there is
a constant
Parashurama outflux so inner side of the
cell is becoming more negative now what
happens is look at this synapse between
a bipolar cell and a photoreceptor cell
when the situation is like dark or there
is no light there is a lot of
neurotransmitter release especially
glutamate release in this terminal and
the neuron is constitutively active it's
a diploid state of these photoreceptor
neuron but whenever there is light less
neurotransmitter is released from the
terminal because now we know because
whenever there is light there is
activity of the cyclic GMP
phosphodiesterase
and reduced activity of our cyclic
nucleotide gated channels and that's why
the neuron cannot be in a depolarize
state the neurons in presence of light
is now in a hyper polarized state you
won't be thinking that ok in a hyper
polarized state how does the neuron send
the signal to the brain how it is
possible
now action potential is just an
all-or-none phenomena it's not similar
like binary code so you might think okay
binary in binary one has a value and
zero also has a value right similarly
having action potential means something
and also not having action potential
means something as will so when there is
a suppression of the activity in
response to light that leads to a
higher-order signal in our visual cortex
which is located at the back side of our
brain and that is processing processed
by higher-order brain centers and that's
how our visual perception is created in
the visual cortex but how the visual
cortex process that signal or decode
that signal that is beyond the
discussion of this particular video now
one of the most important feature of
this pathway is the signal amplification
capability it turns out that one
molecule of rhodopsin can at least
activate 800 molecules of transducing
now transducing can one transducing
molecule can activate one cyclic GMP
phosphodiesterase
but there is a twist the cyclic GMP
phosphodiester stress molecule can at
least hydrolyze six molecules of cyclic
GMP that means if 800 molecules of
cyclic GMP phosphodiesters was activated
by 800 transducing molecule now there
would be 4800 cyclic GMP broken down to
GMP that would lead to massive change in
each step and each step the degree of
change is more and thereby we can
understand the signal amplification now
what happens is there are like several
mechanisms which can allow the cell to
get back to its firing state or restore
its firing state and one such molecule
is beta resting which would sort of
arrest the transducing from interacting
with the phosphodiesterase as a results
I think GMP level would be restored and
build up not only that in
since of transducing activating
phosphodiesterase
there is another molecule known as other
protein known as guanylate cyclase which
would convert GMP to cyclic GMP now all
these mechanism in a combined way would
restore the restored level of cyclic GMP
what it would result is influx of sodium
from outside to inside that means the
cells would be now depolarized and that
is how after you after you see something
your neurons stopped firing for that
time and that is perceived in the higher
brain order brain center and after a
while all the machinery is ready again
to make that neuron constitutively
active so in this video we kind of
looked at the mechanism of signal
transduction the neurobiology behind
phototransduction not only that the
regulation of foreign transaction at a
molecular level I hope you enjoyed this
video if you liked this video give it a
quick thumbs up and please don't forget
to Like share and subscribe and please
let me know in the comment how do you
like my videos thank you